[Music]
the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance
welcome to your weekly ticket
dc's fandom happened this weekend and it
was a lot bigger than most of us thought
it would be
and if you missed it don't worry we got
you covered just prior to fandom
it was announced that ben affleck will
return as batman
in the flash the film which will usher
in a new era of dc movies by introducing
the dc
multiverse will feature characters from
other films
and eras this is of course inspired by
the storyline from the comics which
feature
barry allen aka the flash traveling back
in time
on a mission to save his mother michael
keaton's batman will also make an
appearance in the film
and there was even some concept art
revealed for the film which showed
keaton back as
batman and if that wasn't enough we got
our first look at robert pattinson as
batman
director matt reeves revealed the first
trailer which shows pattinson's dark
gritty and violent new take on the
superhero
the trailer takes inspiration from the
earlier days of bruce wayne as he
transforms into the caped crusader and
shows us some glimpses of multiple
villains like the riddler penguin and
catwoman head over to our site or click
the link below for more on all the big
news
images and trailers dropped during dc
fandom
and will smith and kevin hart are
teaming up for a planes trains and
automobiles remake
paramount pictures will release the
remake of the classic john hughes 1987
road trip comedy
about a mismatched duo forced to become
bunkmates and traveling partners
in a desperate attempt to get home to
loved ones for thanksgiving
after their flights are cancelled hart
announced the news on his instagram
writing
i've been patiently waiting for the
right project to team up with my brother
with
we found it and are developing it
together with our teams
this will be huge for us in the city of
brotherly love aka philadelphia
let's go
that's what it says i gotta do it
from great comedy teams to unbreakable
crime fighting partners to those
love to hate hero villain rivalries
cinema has blessed us with some
incredible
iconic duos and today we're celebrating
by highlighting fandango now's
list of dynamic duos all right today's
guest is fandango correspondent nikki
novak
nikki can you break down your all-time
favorite movie duos for us
can you guess my first one it is back to
the future
oh my gosh kale this is one not only is
it
one of my favorite movie duos but it is
in my top
three movies of all time i think back to
the future is a perfect movie i've said
this before structurally
the way it's edited the suspense and i
actually watched it again last night
just to get in the spirit of things i've
probably seen it already 20 times but i
think
i've kind of narrowed it down for me to
try to describe
why they're such a good duo i could
never do it justice because i think
there's just like a magic between them
there's just like
certain actors that have magic and it's
more than chemistry it's just that
unspoken thing between them
but first of all you had total opposites
you had christopher lloyd who was like
the zany
you know mad professor type character
and then you had michael j
fox who was just pure innocence playing
marty mcfly like there was nothing jaded
about that character
also you had great one-liners for a
great deal you gotta have great
one-liners that people
say 20 years later 30 years later
however long later
but i'm gonna point something out it was
the best use
of eyeball acting ever in film okay
bear with me because think about
christopher lloyd
going and then you've got marty mcfly
you know like the scene where he leans
over in the diner and he sees his dad
for the first time and you see him lean
in and it's just like
like it's so hard the eyeballs
said so much and it's so sometimes when
actors do so much with their face it's
too much but the two of them together
but i just think you felt that mutual
love for each other
and they would do anything for each
other you never believed that these
actors were actors and didn't know each
other before
and that particular pair of duos has
some great lore and that there was
a different marty before and then they
brought in michael j fox and it was like
instant chemistry that's the thing you
know there was no rehearsal time because
they were already filming and they
already had to reshoot so much
and like you would never have known that
and i just love both of them i'm going
to say real quick
a couple of years ago i got to interview
frank marshall one of the producers on
it
and i said to him frank i need a sequel
for back to the future i know people
have very mixed
feelings about that and i said i need a
sequel and he said no way he said who
would you even cast and i'm like
tom holland which everybody's talked
about tom holland and tom holland has
said that he would love to do it they've
even had deep fakes
where they have robert downey jr playing
the doc character
on youtube and he so i said tom holland
and now tom holland has said that
they've had talks about it i know robert
zemeckis has said never and i think he
owns part of the property
but i think tom holland but i don't know
if i would cast robert downey jr i might
cast jeff
goldblum and it's not a reboot it's a
sequel where you bring back michael j
fox as his dad and tom holland's
character finds the delorean is like
what is this all about
oh i love it i would love it i would
love our own episode of like
pitching how that we could get that to
work because i want zendaya in there too
i need i need her in there as well well
she could be the girlfriend
yeah we're going to be the girls for
sure we could talk about back to the
future forever
what is your second one bill and ted's
excellent adventure
again another 80s movie and similar
reasons
why this work between the two actors
with keanu reeves and
alex winter they look i know that they
had a
long audition process and they really
got to know each other
like before they started filming this
but again you have
magic between two people with back to
the future they were opposites these
characters were so
similar they were like the same guy but
i think what really worked about them
is number one they're like almost like
zen they almost have the
the world figured out and how to live a
happy life because they know they're not
the brightest guys and they're okay with
it they're totally okay with who they
are they never try to be something that
they're not
you know they're fine with being
themselves it's such a great message
and the second reason i think it really
works as much as their time
traveling they're so in the moment every
moment they're
in is the most magical amazing excellent
moment they've ever been in and there's
nothing that exists outside of it even
though they're time traveling so both
films have time traveling elements but
both performances they're so locked into
that moment
and actors always talk about the stakes
being high and i think with both of them
the stakes like
everything to them is so cool and so
important and that's why it works and
that's why they're having you know they
had a sequel and now
30 years later bill and ted face the
music's coming out
man i need to watch bill and ted again
it's so great
yeah i just watched them both back to
back and it's like
this is the thing it still works for
2020 and i was still going
dude dude dude excellent after i watch
it anything where you want
like 30 years later you're still quoting
it and you're still like
walking around your house like a crazy
person saying the lines
that's when you know it's magical it's
legendary kind of stuff
you mentioned that you watched the
sequel to bill and ted's excellent
adventure
bogus journey and a lot of the duos on
this list
got sequels but are there any that
didn't get
sequels that you think should have a
sequel
there's a lot i mean i know
i've seen you know fandango's list of
great comedy duos and
if i had to choose one it's it's really
hard to choose
i just want to say for people who have
on our list is dirty rotten scoundrels
for people who've never seen dirty
rotten scandals with michael caine and
steve martin
must see i don't know if a duo like a
sequel would work but central
intelligence is the one that i chose
with the rock and kevin hart
oh yeah because first of all they don't
even have to do central intelligence
they can just do any sort of sequel they
want
i think they are our modern day best
comedy duo
like in 2020 that's who i look to
because again the opposites thing just
their physical stature
even when you see them doing press
together that's a movie in itself the
way that they improv off each other
kevin hart to me is the funniest person
on earth
and the rock just balances him out
perfectly he's hilarious too but kevin
is just
unmatched and the rock's like the most
likable guy in the world
you know so i would love to see central
intelligence i know like i think it got
around
70 on rotten tomatoes i think they can
even make it better
and i think you know ross and thurber
the director who wrote the first one
said we're not making another one
because the rock's busy till 2035.
but 2036 i'm expecting a central
intelligence sequel
you know you're talking about chemistry
it doesn't get any better than that
but if you had to pick two actors
to make a new greatest duo to
rival the rock and kevin hart what do
you got
i cheated a little bit first of all i
had like a sheet and i wrote down like
margot robbie and like ryan gosling and
like i wrote down all these names and i
had arrows going
i've never seen anyone br bring like the
actual
work i get like a back with like a yarn
and stuff you're like you see
okay you should you should see outside
of this peripheral
vision that you have that's everywhere
there's string everywhere
um this was a tough one because there's
so many people i'd love to see work
together there's something
about like joaquin phoenix and shia
labeouf would be cool like something
like that but i don't know what that
would be
but here's what i chose and i'm cheating
a little bit because they've done a
movie together before but this would not
be
anything to do with the movie they did
ryan reynolds and jake gyllenhaal they
did the movie
life now for anybody who watched any of
the interviews they did
they didn't answer one question because
the two of them could not keep straight
faces
they were totally in another planet
the the interviews were the most
entertaining thing i've ever seen
they're dynamic if anybody hasn't seen
any of the press they did
go to youtube you'll thank me later it
was the craziest chemistry i've ever
seen because jake can kind of be
a little serious sometimes and ryan just
got him like into a different realm
so ryan reynolds jake gyllenhaal buddy
cop movie
some some form of a comedy movie they
would make a great comedy duo in my
opinion
that's a great unexpected choice that's
fantastic
you know you definitely did do your
homework i'm impressed because i wasn't
expecting that
but that one is like flawless and i
would expect nothing less
you got any uh junkets coming up well i
might have interviewed the cast of bill
and ted's
face the music so i've got that party on
i got that coming out well look you know
what let's
let's end with uh um an air guitar
and hope that uh our editor vanessa adds
that hand all right
ready
[Applause]
[Music]
i hope she edited it again if not
thanks nikki bye thank you
[Applause]
well the time has finally come theaters
are back
open and at fandango it's our mission to
help you return to the movies with
confidence and peace of mind
so that we can all return to watching
movies on the big screen
and when you're ready fandango is here
to help you return to the movies safely
learn more at fandango.com safety
new in theaters this weekend the new
mutants
what's the last thing you remember danny
he said we had to run
four young mutants are being held in an
isolated hospital for psychiatric
monitoring and dr cecilia reyes believes
the teenagers are a danger to both
themselves and society
making her keep a close eye on them as
she struggles to teach them
how to rein in their mutant abilities
when newcomer danielle
danny moonstar joins the other patients
in the facility
strange occurrences begin to take place
the hospital's patients are plagued by
hallucinations and flashbacks
and their new mutant abilities and their
friendships will be tested as they
battle to try and make it out alive
and if you're looking for something to
watch at home this weekend why not check
out
rogue get down
megan fox tackles a thrilling new role
as a battle-hardened mercenary in this
explosive action saga
as team leader o'hara she leads a lively
squad of soldiers on a daring mission
rescue hostages from their captors in
remote africa
but as the mission goes awry and the
team is stranded o'hara's squad must
face a bloody brutal encounter with a
gang of rebels
and the horde of ravenous enraged lions
they encounter
alright that's it for this week but make
sure to check out that full list of
dynamic duo films in the link below and
let us know in the comments if you're
gonna check out the new mutants
i'm kale and i'll see you next week
[Music]
you